new york wird ihnen präsentiert von
swiss der airline wo in die welt bringt
new york stolz schön fasziniert die
vielleicht legendärsten stadt der welt
aber auch hektisch und chaotisch wir
begleiten fünf schweizer und
schweizerinnen die den sprung über den
großen teich gewagt haben um sich dort
ein neues leben aufzubauen eine
herausforderung nicht umsonst heißt es
wer es in new york schafft schafft es
überall auf der anderen seite bietet die
stadt demjenigen der es wirklich will
nach wie vor unbegrenzte möglichkeiten
[Musik]
morgens um halb sieben im stadtteil
queens
daniela fischer man macht frühstück für
ihre kinder und die lunchbox ist für die
schule denn das kantinenessen ist mies
findet sie
aus diesem grund gibt daniela leon und
lilly das mittagessen mit
um 7 uhr müssen die kinder aufstehen
morgen
finden
[Musik]
auch an der upper east side geht schon
los
[Musik]
greg und christina sind vor einem jahr
eltern geworden sie genießen die
morgendliche routine mit tochter lena
damit alles rund läuft gibt's eine klare
rollenteilung
[Musik]
in der regel weg christina lena und
wechsle windeln ich mache etwas zu essen
normalerweise haferflocken wir sind hier
drehen
und an ein paar trauben oder andere
früchte
und je nachdem wer mehr in alle ist
fitter cilena oder ich wir wechseln uns
ab damit wir uns gleichzeitig für die
arbeit fertig machen können
damit das modell funktioniert haben die
vollzeit juristen eine nanny engagiert
tessy
die gebürtige filipina sieht lena öfter
als ihre eigenen enkel
ich bin sehr weit weg von meiner familie
deswegen behandele ich sie manchmal wie
meine eigene enkelin
ich habe lena beigebracht logo zu sagen
das heißt opa auf philippinische
und lola heißt
und jetzt sagt sie zu meinem mann los
als wäre er ihr opa
es ist wundervoll mit lena und sie ist
die beste in allem was sie macht
während greg und christina ihren jobs
nachgehen wird es später mit lena auf
den spielplatz gehen
kristina hat sich bewusst für die
karriere entschieden
seit rund zehn jahren arbeitet die
juristin hierfür die credit suisse als
rechtliche beraterin der obersten
geschäftsführung
die verantwortung ist groß die tage sind
lang
[Musik]
patric wener ist ebenfalls schon früh
unterwegs im mietauto geht es heute nach
pants oder her der designer braucht
neues edelholz für seine möbel doch
vorher muss er noch einen umweg machen
[Musik]
auf ein brot kaufen
praktikant felix ist noch ein bisschen
sprachlos und überwältigt von den neuen
eindrücken
wir also erst
das ist ein preis der
das buch zieht es auch wochen oder
monate so zu unsicher märklin trix und
wo und was ist und dann könnten sich
dann nicht nur schnell an neue
situationen und her und alles und droht
ein typisch amerikanisches lebensgefühl
auf dem heimweg das hat schon das gefühl
vorprogramm ziellosigkeit irgendwie raus
sb spiel heute fahre mit machine trio
überhaupt schon hier und überhaupt stand
zog das heißt quasi die ganze schweiz
und das ist für ihren thron zu verhelfen
ist eigentlich nicht so verrückt
[Musik]
anna kissling ist eben von einem trip
aus europa zurückgekommen sie lebt seit
sieben jahren in new york und arbeitete
lange für eine werbeagentur
als man hier eine beförderung anbot
kündigte sie überraschend und machte
sich als fashion stylistin selbständig
bis jetzt läuft es gut
und ich
überrasche und gebildete kofferpacken
schwitzen nach stadt und
nicht unbedingt mit lebendem
lieblingsbeschäftigung ihre freizeit
damit wenigstens
die 34 jährige fühlte sich von new york
vom ersten moment an magisch angezogen
und ist beeindruckt von den
möglichkeiten die sich hier bieten
umso weniger kann sie verstehen wie
negativ man in der schweiz menschen
behandelt die einwandern wollen
das liegt ihnen rat oder wir das genaue
konzept wird aber dass negativität und
hass und seine sonne kreist entscheidet
und hospental und richtig also macht
nachdenklich und traurig ich glaube
schon dass ich wichtig scheint
zurück zu den schocker mainz
wenn sie den schulbus nehmen würden
müsste die familie fast eine stunde
früher aufstehen deshalb wird
normalerweise hermanni die kids zur
schule
doch der musiker ist auf tour
die öffentlichen schulen in den usa
haben einen schlechten ruf daniela
bestätigt dass
doch eine private kostet bis zu 30.000
dollar im jahr
das können sich nur die wenigsten
leisten
christinas arbeitstag beginnt schon auf
dem weg dahin zeit ist kostbar und die
juristin daher rund um die uhr im
einsatz
es war wichtig zu nehmen dann lässt
relevant ist einfach los was ist
passiert dass man den job tätig weil man
im job war es passiert
[Musik]
der new yorker sitz der credit suisse
alle wichtigen informationen der bank
die veröffentlicht werden müssen zuvor
von christina geprüft werden
oft genug musste sich dann nochmals mit
den obersten chefs abstimmen
übereinstimmt und sehr wichtig ist
dennoch eine technologie investieren und
schlussendlich ist natürlich nicht meine
entscheidung aber ich wollte wenigstens
sicher sie das leistet was mein
ratschlag wer und was ich wichtig finde
christina marx die arbeit mit ihrem
jungen team
nach erfolgreichen projekten spendiert
sie einen team land als motivation
dass der ruf ihrer branche seit der
großen bankenkrise gelitten hat muss sie
akzeptieren
vor der bank nämlich exakt mexiko ist
das prestigeträchtigste sie da dazumal
führer brauchen konkrete finanzwelt
schaffen war sich zähne sauber ist dass
sich viele andere
kapitalregeln und
möbeldesigner patrick braucht neues holz
nur das beste ist gut genug und das
kriegt man zurzeit bei den amish in
pennsylvania
holz verkäufer john kommt aus einer
amish familie er bestimmt den preis
2800 dollar für ein brett das klingt
verrückt aber die heimische walnuss ist
ihr geld wert denn patricks kundenzahlen
für die besondere qualität
die richtige projekt mit dem
scp die letzte große stadt europäisches
wunderschön ebenso wichtig für mich
einfach als zweimal im jahr der
nettoumsatz
sei der handel mit tropenholz in verruf
geraten ist wird wieder mehr heimisches
holz verlangt
john profitiert von diesem halb die
amish gemeinde zu dir gehört kam
ursprünglich auch aus der schweiz
das ist walnuss das angesagteste moment
alle wollen walnuss ihr mit der natur
kannte wenn es trocken und sauber ist
kann man das einfach beizen oder
lackieren das machst du doch auch zu
oder nicht
die bereiche strom sind
wunderschön die sägerei schließt in
einer stunde bis dahin sollte patrick
seinen stapel zusammen haben
aber
ich glaube ich gar nicht nur historiker
gerissen und pflichten reiz weiteren
schönen der isar breiteres auch suchen
und dann habe ich langsam
weniger dekorativer latten sind
günstiger
die benutzt patrick für
innenverkleidungen am ende kommt wie
immer ein hübsches sümmchen zusammen
der
druck ist wieder versorgt den nächsten
auftrag hat er bereits in der tasche
zurück in queens daniela macht für
einmal nichts
der senf sollte zwischen 7 und 10 uhr
geliefert werden also erstmal würste für
den street food markt aufbauen
das geschäft läuft gut daniela macht in
der regel 200 dollar gewinn pro
wochenende mit dem neuen metzger ist sie
sehr zufrieden
mittlerweile
nur noch 30 minuten soll es dauern wird
sie vertröstet
anna hat einen auftrag für sonntag sie
muss ein model aus starten ins euro gibt
es einen neuen schwung dort kann man
mode für events oder fotoshootings mit
anna checkt die neue location mal aus
leider funktioniert
vielleicht zwei wird eine große show
aber es ist wichtig
als fashion stylistin sind solche
kontakte wichtig
sollte anna demnächst für ein luxus
shooting gebucht werden wüsste sie nun
wo sie edle designer outfits mieten
könnte
[Musik]
also jetzt so im sommer seitige
scheidung wieder
schwierigkeiten eigentlichen arbeitszeit
uns einmal bewusst wird was man nicht
hat
und man wird das allerdings die
möglichkeit findet das lag aber
grundsätzlich schon so sessions also
wenn wir die bäume nur mehr wenig sieht
mir und um mich selbst gesetzt hatte
keinen job also schlussendlich war somit
ganz aus was kann die woche was dann
jedoch etwas hörte zu und muss ich
zahlen
was macht
ein paar tom ford schule kostet um die
50 bis 75 dollar pro tag wir vermieten
aber auch für eine woche für den
doppelten tagespreis ist aber immer
individuell je nach dem was man sind
wichtig
mein gegner noch lesbar oder
so abberger
[Musik]
endlich der senf mit fast zwei stunden
verspätung
es stellt sich heraus dass der fahrer
eine falsche anlieferung zeit erhalten
hat
10 kanister senf bequem nach hause
geliefert
daniela ist für den street food markt
morgen gerüstet
in conneticut ist heute nicht an arbeit
zu denken
uhrmacher harry beutler macht frei und
hat seine familie zum segelausflug
eingeladen
sie wollen freunde besuchen mit ihrem
boot schon draußen warten mit an bord
ehefrau heidi und die beiden söhne
daniel und rhein kommt
das ruder überlässt der berner heute
seinem sohn ryan
der 20-jährige studiert nautik und ist
quasi auf dem wasser groß geworden
freizeitkapitän kann man in amerika
allerdings relativ leicht werden
bürokratie
auf die andere
situation
[Musik]
harry fährt seit 30 jahren dasselbe
schiff als uhrmacher könnte sich
problemlos ein neues leisten aber es ist
ihm wichtig dass man den sachen sorge
trägt eine botschaft hier auch an die
söhne weitergegeben hat
heutzutage kaufen sich die leute alle
fünf jahre ein neues auto oder dies neue
und das neue wir haben denselben job
seit 15 jahren dasselbe segelboots dass
sie schon vor ihrer hochzeit hatten und
alles noch in gutem zustand das hatte
uns sicher auch mit gegeben dass man auf
die sache nachgeht
weiter geht die fahrt vorbei an den
luxuriösen strandvillen der gut und
besser verdienenden
harry genießt was er erreicht hat immer
ein bisschen mit schweizer
understatement eine eigenschaft die
seine frau heidi allem sehr schätzt
hier wird sehr viel wert auf erfolg geld
und karriere gelegt doch harry und ich
haben diese balance
es muss einen punkt geben an dem man
sagt jetzt haben wir alles und jetzt ist
es wichtiger den job job sein zu lassen
weg vom computer und sich zeit für die
menschen zu nehmen die einem wichtig
sind
in brooklyn im zentrum der jüdischen
gemeinde steht heute ein shooting an
[Musik]
die location hat anna besorgt dazu einen
haufen outfits fotograf sektor perez
setzt sein model warschau ins
spannungsfeld zwischen natur und
urbanität jedes motiv sondern eine
geschichte erzählen
wenn es um mode geht sind die outfits
natürlich am wichtigsten und selbst bei
diesen persönlichen projekt hier sind
sie super wichtig weil sie dir einen
look vorgeben und eine richtung am
strand auf dem dach in new york in
anderen städten das outfit ist
eigentlich der rote faden
sektor möchte heute auch das wilde
brooklyn einfangen entsprechend
unkonventionell sind die outfits
da anna auch klamotten aus ihrem eigenen
fundus dabei hat sind manchmal tricks
nötig
model war hat mit den sexy outfits kein
problem die amerikaner manchmal aber
schon
[Musik]
christina und greg genießen den
feierabend auf der terrasse
luxus in new york eine kleine oase für
die eltern und für töchterchen lena die
chance ein bisschen natur zu erleben
[Musik]
ja
seit der geburt von tochter lena ist das
familienglück perfekt
und trotzdem
eine sorge die eltern christinas eltern
können nicht mehr reisen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
macht spaß doch es bleibt eine notlösung
christina war schon immer viel unterwegs
in früheren jahren als model
[Musik]
kristina hat zwischen natur und studium
einige jahre erfolgreich als model
gearbeitet unter anderem auch in kino
und tv spots
[Musik]
tochter lena ist begeistert
[Gelächter]
auch für magazine wie harper's bazaar
oder die italienische vogue wurde
christina abgelichtet doch alles auf die
model karte zu setzen war ihr zu riskant
die
schweiz und hat ein auto nie aufhören
jus studieren in conneticut toppen harry
und die familien crew an das motorboot
ihrer freunde an kleine partys dieser
art werden hier oft gefeiert
paris kumpel mike ist gebäudemanager und
kein schweizer was sagt ihr zum thema
bankgeheimnis
immerhin führte der druck der amerikaner
dazu dass viele schweizer in amerika
ihre schweizer konten schließen und zu
einer us bank wechseln mussten
ich glaube die meisten leute hier wissen
gar nichts von dieser bank geschichte
manchmal liest man was in der zeitung
stand etwas über die neuen gesetze und
dass es nun schwieriger es geld auf
schweizer banken zu verstecken
aber ich glaube die meisten leute sind
sich gar nicht bewusst was hier läuft
jahrhunderts
[Musik]
auf dem rückweg kommt sogar ein bisschen
wind auf nun ist jeder hand gefragt
[Applaus]
allein
ryan und
[Musik]
wenig
die ganze familie schauen wir noch toll
und jetzt das modell mit der große
angriff ist natürlich wieder eine
sachgerechte und dass der bruch bereits
kurz team und
die familie momente so fehler machen und
so gemacht 1 5 1 von gut im griff
harry und heidi haben mit ihren söhnen
reihen und daniel immer viel unternommen
die jungs haben aus beiden kulturen
einiges mitgenommen und sich das
herausgepickt was sie für nachahmenswert
hielten
wir machen viele tolle sachen aber es
ist selten wirklich spontan wenn wir in
den urlaub fahren hat mein vater schon
immer alles genau geplant um die und die
zeit frühstücken wir dann gehen wir
dahin machen dass das und das dann ist
mittagspause danach fand ihr kajak dann
müssen wir noch in dieser eine bar also
er war es immer schon ganz genau was wir
dort machen wenn wir ankommen
wir sind etwas entspannter als unser
bett wenn es ums reisen geht
zurück in brooklyn das team hat das
shooting auf die dachterrasse verlegt
oberes wird in seinem fotobuch
verschiedene facetten seines models
einfangen die outfits sollen auch sexy
sein eine herausforderung für stylisten
anna
und natur und nur
hat die wende
[Musik]
der job heute ist ein sogenannter am
cape anna verspricht sich von der
buchpublikation größere bekanntheit
außerdem reizt sie das kreative
geld verdient die stylistin an anderen
tagen
ich muss ganz für andere jobs machen
womöglich um bezahlte jobs machen dass
die werbeagenturen und du sie glitt rufe
und das in einer kurzzeitig jobs aber
die sind natürlich merkt ob sie
trainieren
und so super high
school
shootings wie das heute gleich in den
stress wieder aus sagt anna selbständig
ist kann sie ihre projekte frei
auswählen sie sieht sich in ihrem
entschluss bestätigt gekündigt zu haben
[Musik]
darum habe ich einen job findet und ich
werde mache
designer patrick weder und assistent
felix auf dem weg zu einer stammkundin
im central park west der vielleicht
teuersten wohngegend der stadt hier
wohnt die galeristin helle rosenfeld
willkommen in unserem zuhause wo wir
patricks talent und handwerkskunst in
fast jedem raum genutzt haben
hier stehen wir vor einem unglaublichen
kaffee unser besuch fragte man nach
diesem tisch und ich glaube ich habe
patrick sparte deswegen schon tausendmal
verteilt
für den designer sind empfehlungen wie
die von rwe norm wichtig ihre
geschäftsbeziehung begann mit einem
nachttisch seitdem kam einiges dazu
ich sage also ungefähr in niederhone
jetzt da wahrscheinlich so 100 oder 200
fans waren zwischen moskau und dann in
der galerie verstehen lernen so viel
drin also ja ich bin darin sich sehr
gute runde von mir
patrick ich habe ein neues problem das
zu lösen ist ich brauche hier eine
arbeitsfläche besonders für ruby sie
liebt es zu nehmen aber das dauert
manchmal
nicht nur patricks künstlerische
fähigkeiten sind gefragt sondern auch
seien praktisch verstand
patrick ist ein problemlöser er schafft
etwas das funktioniert und auch noch
toll aussieht
für sie natürlich gern machen solche
arbeiten erledigt patrick nur noch für
seine stammkunden
ansonsten sucht er sich die projekte aus
[Musik]
es ist ein felix ist beeindruckt und ein
bisschen auf er ahnt wie lang der weg
zum erfolg im big apple sein kann
alles was man braucht nur mehr will als
künstler ab jetzt auch liebe wird
der street food markt in brooklyn
daniela steht wieder an ihrem star
wurststand der umsatz steigt mit jedem
wochenende
in new york
you can make it anywhere
ich habe
viel weiß ich was ich nicht
gleich neben dem markt spielt leon
fußball
daniela gönnt sich eine kurze pause um
ihren sohn mit der nummer 11 zu
unterstützen
sind wir das spiel verloren auch ihr
mann ist zurück aus brasilien
[Musik]
die schnitzel hertie wie das ist
training coaches sind alles
und vor allem in queens kommen die
kinder mit ihren kulturen in berührung
das war früher war uns anders ich hoffe
dass es dazu führt dass unsere kinder
insgesamt offener werden
daniela ist zurück camstar wurststand
seit zwei monaten hilft hier an den
wochenenden eine studentin und mit der
bratwurst vom neuen metzger ist sie fast
zufrieden
leon hat zu viel sonne abbekommen doch
daniela muss sich kurz um die kunden
kümmern
ihre firma star wurst steht noch am
anfang aber die zürcherin hat ein klares
ziel vor augen
aus der multitalentierte schweizerin ist
eine multikulturelle new yorkerin
geworden
anna hat ausnahmsweise schon feierabend
zeit über ihre private zukunft
nachzudenken
einen festen freund gibt es momentan
nicht die wohnung teilt sie mit einem
mitbewohner
doch die 34 jährige weiß genau wo sie in
fünf jahren sein möchte
muss und darf
und
es fließen automatisch ich suche nicht
nach einem partner wird die kriterien
der richtig
[Musik]
patrick hat seine frau tameka zu einem
abend bummel abgeholt die beiden sind
seit 18 jahren ein paar
tamika ist new yorkerin wer jedoch
glaubt der gebürtige zürcher sei nur
hier zuliebe hier geblieben
[Musik]
jeder glaubt ich möchte hier bleiben
klarer ich mag new york aber er ist
derjenige der new york wirklich liebt
und er liebt mich
stimmt ich würde gerne am zürichsee
leben das letzte mal als wir atrix
elternhaus besucht haben habe ich
gefragt wie konntest du hier weggehen es
ist so schön
es wird abend in new york
und während patrick und amica heute bei
ihrem williams burger lieblingsitaliener
einkehren ort christinas ehemann greg an
diesem abend selbst
ein spezieller lieferservice bringt neue
kochrezepte mit den entsprechenden
zutaten direkt nach hause
heute gibt es kaktus
das koche ich heute die zutaten werden
geliefert bohnen portals reis tomaten
knoblauch alles und immer genau die
menge die man für das gericht braucht
und ich koche dann
es ist für leute die keine zeit haben
einzukaufen
christina lernte greg kennen als sie vor
20 jahren das erste mal nach new york
kam
[Musik]
dabei erzählt gezielt nach einem
amerikanischen mann gesucht im gegenteil
die starren dating regeln der amerikaner
haben die juristin anfangs eher
abgeschreckt
[Musik]
sonst hat sich ganz natürlich
[Applaus]
auf uhrmacher harry und seine familie
wartet ein leckeres buffet der schweizer
ski club bittet zum tanz
für gattin heidi hat der club eine
besondere bedeutung schließlich haben
sich harry und sie vor 30 jahren auf
einer ski club party ineinander verliebt
wir waren nicht die einzigen wir sind
mit vielen familien in die skiferien
gefahren und unsere söhne sind halte
auch hier dieser club ist neben meiner
familie das größte was ich habe er ist
wie eine familie
die familiäre stimmung des schweizer ski
clubs ist noch so gut wie vor 70 jahren
als er gegründet wurde der schweizer
anteil allerdings ist nicht mehr ganz so
hoch wie damals
erich ist ein guter freund der familie
der textilhändler hat die diskussion um
das schweizer bankgeheimnis als
schweizer in new york erlebt und ist ein
bisschen enttäuscht
die stimmung steigt
je später der abend desto ehrlicher die
voten wie viel schweiz steckt noch in
harry söhnen wollen wir wissen
50% rechnerisch doch wenn man ein land
nur aus erzählungen oder ein paar
besuchen kennt
ich bin amerikaner das ist die kultur in
der ich aufgewachsen bin aber ich
schätze die schweizer kultur die
schweizer küche ich habe meine schweizer
id dabei
ich bin zur hälfte schweizer ich spreche
die sprache nicht aber ich habe es im
blut doch ich spreche die sprache nicht
reichenhofen
und so mischt sich doch noch ein
bisschen wehmut in die partystimmung
aber sonst hat harry wohl das meiste
richtig gemacht
[Musik]
patrick kam vor 20 jahren nach new york
fast ohne englischkenntnisse
dafür mit talent und leidenschaft
[Musik]
ich glaube weil patrick ist einfach
gemacht hat hat er gar nicht gemerkt wie
mutig das war es ist wirklich hart auch
für amerikaner oder new yorker oder
künstler allgemein
aber ich denke new york hat ihm die
möglichkeit gegeben die person zu sein
die er sein wollte
damit wird endlich fiel natürlich oder
rette mich später die werden natürlich
die eltern und meiner natur vermisst mir
ganz recht so pitz aber
für mich heute so viel zeit und energie
kurse in new york investiert schloss in
new york bleibt eine herausforderung
unsere fünf schweizer haben sie
angenommen und ihren weg gefunden jeder
auf seine art in der legendärsten stadt
der welt
[Musik]
orden new york erschienen ist
präsentiert wurde der airline wo
entdecke die welt bringt